all right guys apple just released the
new 2020
budget 10.2 inch ipad and as you saw in
the title
i'm telling you guys to definitely buy
this
ipad let me explain last year i told you
guys
not to buy the new 2019 10.2 inch ipad
and instead just buy the previous 9.7
inch model
since they were very similar and they
had the same exact
a10 fusion processor but six months
later
the 10.2 inch ipad got some really great
updates
so i made another video giving you guys
three reasons why that ipad
was now a great deal in 2020 the first
reason was that it went on sale for the
same 250
dollars as the previous one was second
it got updated with cursor support for
the first time
ever and third it was the first budget
ipad to come with the smart connector
which meant compatible keyboards like
apple's smart keyboard and
logitech's combo touch can get powered
directly by that smart connector
this means no batteries no charging and
instant connection meaning that this
10.2 inch ipad
could now replace a laptop and i
recommended everyone to go and buy it
but there was still that one
disappointment about
the updated 10.2 inch ipad and that was
the performance
apple decided to use this same a10
processor
that was in the old budget ipad and this
processor is noticeably weaker
than the rest of the ipads in apple's
lineup
it actually struggles a lot with more
demanding games
like fortnite asphalt 9 pubg
and call of duty mobile when we put it
up against the ipad mini in the ipad air
3 with the a12 bionic chip
and the ipad pro with the a12z chip the
performance of the 10.2 inch ipad was
embarrassing the 10.2 inch ipad was
basically twice
as slow as the a12 chip ipads and
geekbench 5's multi-core test
this means that the budget ipad is worse
for simple daily tasks like opening
apps and browsing the web but it's even
more noticeable if you want to do things
like photo
and video editing to be honest though
for the things that people buy a budget
ipad for
the cpu performance is decent enough at
least at the time
you're buying it but where things really
take a turn is
the graphics in geekbench 5's metal
graphics test
it scored 2 700 points compared to over
4500
for the ipad air and the ipad mini and
if you've been watching our videos
more and more apps are making use of
metal for acceleration
it also performed noticeably worse in
gaming with antutu's gpu test
resulting in 77 000 points for the
budget ipad
compared to 180 000 that's a massive
difference
when playing pubg there were times where
it would drop frames and be stuttery
especially in higher texture
environments but when we switched to the
ipad mini with the a12 chip
all of the drop frames went away and was
able to run
pubg perfectly now when i switched over
to fortnite
even in the lobby the texture and
graphics quality was noticeably worse
than the rest of the ipads and that
quickly translated over into the game
i noticed quite a bit of aliasing and
even though the settings were set to
60fps
in game we actually got 40 to 50 fps
most of the time
with occasional stuttering and drops
down to 20 fps
in comparison not only did the ipad
mini's graphics look much
nicer but it stayed maxed out at 60fps
the entire time
which definitely helps you play a lot
better now because of that
i ended up recommending people to get
the ipad mini instead
even if it means having a smaller
display but now
the brand new 8th gen 10.2 inch ipad is
getting updated
with the same a12 bionic chip that
performs much better
with its six core cpu and quad-core gpu
resulting in a huge performance boost
not only that
but it will also be the first budget
ipad with a neural engine
which dramatically speeds up things such
as machine learning
camera quality and speed photo editing
and much more
all while using less power along with
that you also get much faster data
transfer speeds if you buy
an lte model this updated hn ipad is
going to be priced
at the same 329 dollars and 299 dollars
for students
so it's a great deal being cheaper than
the ipad mini
while providing a bigger display and
keyboard support
and much much cheaper than the new ipad
air 4
that now starts at 600 so apple kept all
of the great things about the 10.2 inch
ipad
like the low price the big screen with
the keyboard and cursor support
while fixing the one main complaint we
had about it
which will not only make it run faster
and much smoother today
but also years down the line if you're
thinking about buying one
we would highly recommend it and i'll
leave links to
the new budget ipad down in the video
description including our recommended
keyboard case
if you enjoy this video go ahead and tap
the like button and click the circle
above to subscribe because we're getting
that ipad in
very soon and definitely check out our
apple product merch
like our hoodie and our mask down below
thanks for watching and we'll see you
in the next one
[Music]
you